if Louise could have bought anything in
the world it would have been more time
for her son
George had an aggressive cancer the
tumor in his brain was the size of a
golf ball
to treat it his parents raised nearly
half a million pounds but with limited
options for clinical trials in England
they had to spend it elsewhere we never
ever expected to be disadvantaged by
living in England we always thought we
had an amazing healthcare system which I
still believe we have but in the area of
brain tumors and brain tumor research
and advances in what's happened in
medicine in that area it's been
absolutely shocking there's an
explanation for that of 40 million
pounds allocated towards studying brain
tumors only 15 million has reached
researchers Charities say it should be
given the same urgency as the pandemic
the root of the vaccine there was a
spirit of innovation there was a golden
age of Life Sciences and we looked to
the scientists to provide the answer
we've got to make that look to the
scientists again in this area and
identify brain tumors as a critical
priority to achieve that there's an
all-party parliamentary group on brain
tumors it says the current system of
funding research is too complicated so
for example laboratory work isn't
connected with what's happening in
clinics and there's no database for
people to find out what sort of clinical
trials they may have access to and all
of that leaves brain tumor research way
behind that of other diseases like
leukemia and breast cancer the
government says it has invested in every
suitable application made but the appg
wants 110 million pounds ring fenced we
need to pull all of the work that is
going on to make sure that simple things
like tissue samples can be shared right
across the brain cancer research
community and more access to clinical
trials because when people have a
a brain tumor diagnosed and they know
the prospects are not very good they're
very very keen to take part in Trials
George died aged 13. his parents are
backing the appg's plans so that
families don't have to travel thousands
of miles when there's already a mountain
to climb
Saudia Chowdhury Sky News